[Musik]
absteigen da ich ja letztes mal mein
gott ich sah den schmerz in ihren herzen
aus ihren augen hervortreten als ich
nicht gesehen hatte dass sie kein sakko
an haben aber jetzt haben sie schon
wieder ganz anders ist das jetzt die
neue corona posten einander motto sagen
alle leute sagen sie wollen ihr leben
ändern ich bin der einzige der es
wirklich heiß werden sie merken sind
sich aber dann sind sie team risiko und
mit ihm vor sich das waren meine
absoluten absoluten lieblings begriffe
dafür gange noch ein team vorsicht und
team risiko und bei irgendeiner
kindersendung weiß ich mehr genau wie
susan und ob du recht hast oder nicht
sagte gleich das licht aber es ist ich
finde dass es ehrt ihn panik gegenüber
team von und wenn ich das sagen darf er
das wird ihnen jetzt wahrscheinlich
nicht gefallen vielleicht auch dem ein
oder anderen zu wissen wer zu hause
etwas wie panik ist das risiko und die
vorsicht die in panik sind die leute die
uns diesen ganzen schlamassel
eingebrockt haben die sozialen das
gesamte land still gelegt haben
auf den verdacht hin ausser den verdacht
hin dass die krankheit ihnen so aus dem
ruder laufen könnte dass wir hier eine
riesengroße gesundheitliche katastrophe
haben auf diesen verdacht hin haben sie
das gesamte land still gelegt obwohl
korrigieren sie mich sie können gerne
vielleicht irre ich mich habe nicht
genug gelesen ich bin noch recherchiert
kann einem immer fehler können passieren
ich habe keinen text oder hinweis
gefunden der sagt dass es sicher ist
dass man nicht mit weniger strikten
maßnahmen also das gewohnte händewaschen
entschuldigung händewaschen hygiene
socialis dancing dass man nicht mit
weniger maßnahmen genau den gleichen
effekt erzielt hätte wie der den mann
jetzt hat habe ich nicht erleben in den
bericht falsch treffen oder nein sie
haben völlig richtig recherchiert sie
können nichts kann man nicht finden war
das ja nicht da ist ganz einfach es ist
quasi unwiderlegbar was sie sagen nein
man ist nicht weil sie jetzt mal das
gegenteil nicht beweisen kannst du mir
zu viel davon sie das gegenteil nicht
beweisen können kann selber nicht wie
anfangs habe ich habe ziemlich aktiv als
einsteiger normalerweise aus können sie
ganze ich finde dass dafür steht ein
bisschen viel auf dem spiel
dass sie jetzt also logl ein draußen
keine logen sie machen eine leiter aus
und ich möchte kurz für die
angeschlossenen funkhäuser einen service
zu verlesen den ich am 18.4 des jahres
verfasst habe den kreis der beweiskette
bald werden die neo augstein und die alt
rechten kritiker der chor ohne
einschränkungen ursache und wirkung
verdrehen und sagen wäre alles gar nicht
nötig gewesen weil 2020 nicht mehr
menschen in deutschland sterben als
sonst auch das ist das berühmte
präventions- paradoxen ganzen sind die
erklärt fernsehen einander wenn wir hier
sind auch eher fernseh wir haben auch
ein aufklärungs auftrag das per
präventionspreis bedeutet dass man also
maßnahmen macht zur vermeidung einer
krankheit in diesem fall
und dann tritt sozusagen die krankheits
wirkung die gefürchtete nicht ein
und dann kommen so böse corona leugner
so wie ich praktisch meinetwegen zum
beispiel und sagen das wäre ja gar nicht
notwendig gewesen weil die maßnahme
nicht eingetreten sind
das ist sozusagen weil die toten eher
weil die ganze hat auch weil die
befürchteten entdeckte dass das
präventionsprojekt das man nennt es die
response ich würde mal ich würde mal um
müssen ein bisschen mehr unterkriegen
lassen
ich kann mir sagen vorbeugend ein ja und
jetzt in andern es ist aber ein total
es ist ein nicht per mails argument dass
sich selber imprägniert weil das können
sie halt nicht falsifiziert das können
sie bei allen sachen aber immer dazu
sagen sie könnten mich jetzt erschießen
und sagen es war am hof endlich mal am
morgen mit seinem auto eine alte oma um
gefahren hätte und deshalb musste ich
ihn aus dem weg
das können sie auch nicht beweisen
bringen sie mich jetzt nicht in
versuchung es war es war das haben sie
nämlich in versuchung zu denn sie habe
ich ein wenig kann man jetzt mal zurück
zum übernehmen als sollte gemäss zwei
sätze sind nicht zu beweisen
erstens der satz ist brauchte unbedingt
genau diese maßnahmen um eine große
pandemie in deutschland zu verhindern
den satz können sie nicht beweisen ihren
satz
es hätte auch die hälfte getan oder ein
viertel und wir hätten genau dieselben
ergebnisse von reduktion einhegung
erreicht können sie auch nicht beweisen
dafür gibt es aber auch eine menge
plausibel die kinder in der stadt sein
das ist nicht ändern der polizei ist auf
meiner seite wesentlich mehr
plausibilität aber halten wir mal fest
und denn darum geht es mir um den punkt
richtig felsenfest abschließend
beweisbar 2 und 2 4 sind wieder der eine
doch der andere satz und das bringt die
politik in der lage in der sie war man
sechs acht wochen zurück man muss es
dann schon paranoid und noch einen
begriff zu bringen ich finde auch der
zeit heraus beurteilen
auf der lage der fakten die man hatte
auf der basis der erfahrungen die andere
länder mit der pandemie bereits gemacht
hatten weil sie so 14 tage ein bisschen
länger vielleicht auch schon im voraus
quasi den deutschen ereignissen vor
wegliefen war vorbeugung glaube ich dass
politisch 13 mögliche gebot und es sie
ist ja auch in den etappen es ist
rhetorisch derartig aufgerüstet worden
aller kürzester zeit hieß es es geht
darum leben zu retten
wir retten leben retten sie leben durch
social disney sing machen sie mit der
bundespräsident eine rede gehalten
sie haben leben gerettet das heißt man
hat in der rhetorik die erwartungen so
hoch geschraubt dass auch die
politischen maßnahmen sozusagen immer
der der der den der den erwartungen die
durch die rhetorik erzeugt wurden
hinterher hecheln mussten und deshalb
man ehrlich gesagt darüber können wir
gleich vielleicht noch reden auch
verdammt schwer aus der ganzen
geschichte herausgekommen ist weil man
sich gegenseitig so hochgeschaukelt hat
ich finde dass die plausibilität ich
hatte ganz kurz zu jung sie sind kein
biologe ich bin kein pneumologe die
verstehen sowieso von der ganzen sache
nichts also können wir immer nur lesen
lesen lesen und ich habe jetzt gerade
gestern vorgestern interview gelesen mit
dem herausgeber der zeitung neurologie
ihr habe ich auch immer noch nicht
abonniert der sich vielleicht aber
machen der hat den sehr sehr schön fast
poetischen namen möchte ich sagte
santiago ewig toller name vielleicht für
ein crooner roman und er hat gesagt der
aufwand war zu groß wir hätten dieses
ergebnis mit weniger zeit haben könnten
und der typ der macht das halt
hauptberuflich und jetzt sagen kann
jetzt mal nicht jetzt kommen sie mir
nicht mit an drosten der ist halt wiro
aber wir sind jetzt neu das findet der
mittelmärker die sich mit dieser
epidemiologie beschäftigen und
offensichtlich ihre sachen auch mal
besser mal schlechter angriff haben wir
das beispiel ist nur auf die versuchen
sie zu erschießen und anderen menschen
das leben oder auch nur lebenszeit beim
zuhören zu retten
zurück sie können doch jetzt nicht einen
neurologen gegen einen virologen city
quartetts spielen also mein biologe hat
aber zwei doktortitel ist das sagt ja
kinder und sie haben eine warm einer
halb drei hat wie man nach außen hin
aber ist doch interessant wie gehen sie
denn vor gehen sie gehen vor mit den
händlern mit den bildern aus bergamo
mit dem ausgedachten geschichten aus new
york über ist das gesundheitssystem in
new york nicht zusammengebrochen
entschuldigung es ist nicht nein wir
haben uns auch fantasie geschichten
erzählt gegen sagen sie was gefragt also
new yorker 20.000 tote ja das system ist
aber nicht zusammengebrochen hat mich
doch immer gesagt es ist
zusammengebrochen können sie aber im
zeitfahren lese es hat aber auch einen
ruck gegeben vielleicht wäre es
zusammengebrochen mutmaßt sogar es war
auch gut im blick zusammenzubrechen bei
20.000 toten in wenigen wochen was
deutlich mehr ist als sonst das können
wir zumindest mal als faktum stehen
lassen sie haben mich gefragt was ich
mit widersprüchlichen wissenschaftlern
oder widersprüchen unter wissenschaft
machen und dann würde ich wie
tschuldigung daniel kehlmann halten
großes vorbild autor und roman autor
zeigt auch ein bisschen
wissenschaftshistoriker autor der in der
süddeutschen zeitung gesagt hat das ist
das wesen von wissenschaftlicher lesen
hat einen text dann habe ich es endlich
gelesen der rede der heimatstadt sagt
denn dass soll total übertrieben war
moment denn er sagt vor allen dingen in
der wissenschaft sollte es nicht
verwundern wenn die wissenschaftler sie
steigern und damit muss die politik
umgehend das ist genau mein ganzer punkt
ich vertraue natürlich dem einen
wissenschaftler mehr als dem anderen
aber das überlasse ich ihnen dann ihre
wahl zu treffen
nur die politiker müssen da wir sind sie
gewählt ihre wahl treffen wem sie da
mehr hören und dann müssen sie natürlich
vorbeugen ist der islam ist und dann
sagen alle handeln und sie mir natürlich
im essener handels- und das ist das was
wir hier haben ist weil man sich in das
innen das in dieses bild von
präventions- paradox total verliebt hat
weil man erkannt hat dass das bild von
präventions- paradox einen auch schützt
vor jeder nachdrücken kritik denn das
problem ist doch dass die die denkfigur
des präventionsrates verhindert dass man
im nachhinein diese maßnahmen überhaupt
irgendwie noch besprechen kann
denn man kann immer sagen jede einzelne
maßnahme war notwendig um genau das
auszuschließen worüber wir jetzt deshalb
nicht mehr reden können das ist echt
tricky muss ich sagen und das ärgert
mich und ich rede nicht über die
wirtschaft ich rede nicht darüber die
schulden und über ob der euro jetzt über
den bach geht darüber rede ich gar nicht
sondern ich rede über das
zehntausendfache hunderttausendfache
leid was man leuten zugefügt hat die man
in die einsamkeit getrieben hat jetzt
und die kinder die man aus den schulen
rausgenommen hat und das hat man getan
warum auf einen verdacht und deshalb war
martin harnik sie haben es getan auf
einen verdacht und wie ich finde
begründeten verdacht und natürlich
regelt diese bestimmten sinne regelt
dass prävention sparks und letztes mal
zur wahl und das wort zu erwähnen
natürlich die debatte nicht ab denn die
führen wir gerade also was soll die
unterstellung jetzt können wir gar nicht
mehr debattiert ich ertrage es echt
nicht mehr und das ist wirklich ein
bisschen mit sie kommen doch dem
schlagwort und sagen auch schon sie
können es nicht beweisen ich kann es
nicht beweisen ein neues theme und
anleihen überhaupt nicht neues thema da
können wir gerne weiter reden nur aus
ihrer erhabenen position von gewissheit
das war auf gar keinen fall nötig weil
es sind ja nicht so viele gestorben
diese position können sie das kann nicht
die prämisse das kann nicht der beginn
der diskussion sein
sie werden dann schon im einzelnen
nachweisen müssen dass es zum beispiel
überflüssig war so lange gaststätten zu
zu halten da können sie argumentieren
draußen hätten dieses schon machen
können was soll das denn jetzt haben wir
den nächsten es ja auch noch den draußen
umsatz für zwei monate kaputt gemacht da
hätte man es weiter auseinander ziehen
könnte ich sofort dabei bei schulen tut
mir leid tut mir leid wenn ich aber nur
weil mir selber bedenke wie viel zeit
ich in der schule verschlafen habe da
hätte ich mir wenn meine schulkarriere
fünf pandemien leisten können und wäre
immer noch da raus ich habe wo ich raus
gekommen
aber ohne sie kann man zur besserung das
ist ein dass das schul paradox mal weiß
nicht was aus ihnen geworden wäre aber
das sowieso die ganzen kontingents des
seins dass man nie weiß was passiert
wäre wenn auch etwas anders die
tatsachen ich hoffe nicht dass es gab
früher wenn zeitmagazin zeus weinstein
slogan laien und dass man so eine
loreley macht jetzt aus der ganzen
geschichte nein es ist total ernst und
übrigens können wir schon überlegen
würde das leben natürlich wenn wir
wissen dass arbeitslosigkeit durchaus
krank machen kann
das sorge um die existenz um die
wirtschaftliche existenz durchaus krank
ist hat wenn wir in zukunft gucken gar
nicht es könnte natürlich sein dass
diese sehr schlecht altert wenn er drei
wochen ein unfassbarer rebound gekommen
ist und ich nun tatsächlich in einem
sehr schlechten in einem in einer
radarstation nach alaska verbannt werden
soll
das wäre natürlich noch möglich das
glaube ich aber übrigens nicht darauf
wurde ich übrigens auch fast weg
es ist doch und noch ein punkt sie
mindestens in teilen widerlegt ist ja
maßlos meinen sie natürlich auch und zu
recht könnte man ja mein auf mit blick
auf die wirtschaftlichen folgen wie
gesagt aber zusätzlichkeit existenzangst
ich weiß nicht was kann schon auch krank
machen kann auch leute echt in ihrer
lebenserwartung beschädigen und
beeinträchtigen das problem ist halt nur
das mit dem national
lockdown sicherlich bestimmte teile der
wirtschaftlichen schäden zu erklären
sind aber ganz gewiss mich alles an das
ist doch gar nicht in schweden ist doch
immer ihr vorbild gewesen
wollen sie dann so zart mit dem thema so
dass ich gar nicht sprechen nur einen
punkt machen
schweden ist doch immer ihr vorbild
gewesen weil dies tatsächlich noch ein
bisschen laxer gehandhabt haben aus
regierungssicht und die wirtschaftlichen
schäden sind es hat gleich gross gesagt
der sah ich groß wie in deutschland
deshalb genau weil ich das weiß habe ich
das thema nicht angeschnitten und beugte
sich heute über ihr habe ich wollte ich
rede vor allen dingen tschuldigung ich
bin halt ein gefühls linker ich wollte
tatsächlich mehr die psychosozialen
folgen besprechen ich glaube noch mal
über die kinder die komischerweise fast
gar keine rolle gespielt hat wäre der
ganzen debatte warum weil kinder hat
keine lobby haben anders als
autokonzerne gastronomen hotelbetriebe
oder fußball brigens sich dass sie ein
gefühls linke sind ich glaube sie sind
ein tübinger grünert bleibe ich glaube
sie sind boris palmer zählen sie die
meisten ziehen sie aber auch boris
palmer so nett ist bis jetzt es war so
ein nettes gespräch jetzt werde ich hier
noch so gut ist und so ziehen sie die
maske ab boris palmer
[Musik]